So this video allows me to work in one of my favorite words in astronomy,
which I wanted to put into a video for a long time,
which is CCG Susan. Isn't that a great word?
Good for Scrabble sizzle G in astronomy is a co-align
moment, a lining up of three bodies in some sort of gravitational alignment.
So we're used to this all the time. When we have eclipses,
we've got a synergy of the earth and the sun and the moon in different
combinations, depending on which kind of eclipse it is.
And yesterday there was a scissor G in the solicit system because the
planet Jupiter was it opposition.
And that means it is directly opposite the sun as seen from
earth. So we're here on earth. The sun is in one direction,
Jupiter's directly opposite, which makes it great for viewing.
And we get a clear view. It's up all night. It's really bright and very nice.
And so this made me think, how do we get from one planet to another,
if Jupiter is an opposition,
which means it's pretty much just close as it's going to get to us,
wouldn't this be the best time to be sending a mission to Jupiter?
And the answer of course is no. Um,
and so what we're going to explore in this video today is the challenges of
moving around the solar system when everything else is in motion,
and we've got gravity to contend with.
One of my favorite recent series has been the expanse.
Have you seen the expanse? You would love the expanse.
It's a story that's entirely set in the solar system so that the solar system
has been colonized.
The other planet Sydney in the asteroid belt have been colonized,
a real prominent character in the stories is gravity is the
challenges of getting round the solar system and the challenges of growing up
and living in lower gravity environments, what that means.
And particularly the challenges of getting from one place to the other and
everything that that involves.
So that's kind of what I wanted to talk about today because you know,
all the graphics that we see of the solar system have planets lined up,
you know, in a line, you would see that, obviously not to scale.
No, and Australia is upside down, which I like. I can see it right in Australia.
Just for you and Annie. And even in science fiction that this happens a lot.
You think, right? You're going to Jupiter.
And then you go a little further and you get to Saturn.
There's no Pluto. Pluto is not a planet.
We did a whole video. I'm leaving. Okay.
The point is, the planets are not, we all know this,
the planets are not arranged in this nice line, just because we get to Jupiter.
Doesn't mean that if we go a little further,
we get to Saturn because these things are actually orbiting in circles around
the sun or ellipses. And, you know,
Jupiter might be over here in one configuration and Saturn might be.
Way over here ever been in a perfect line.
Um,
I'm sure we could cycle back through the solar system calculator and find lots
of Cisco GS in the solar system.
I don't think it's very likely that everything has been in the line. Um,
but that would be a neat thing.
Maybe that's where they started
really trolling me today. Okay. So this is a view.
Of where the solar system planets are today. At least the inner solar system,
starting from Jupiter, Jupiter with its spot there.
And then Mars is over here. And then,
because I said that Jupiter is an opposition.
That means that the earth and the sun and Jupiter in a straight line,
and then further in,
you've got Venus and you've got mercury and the inner planets are zipping around
much faster. The outer planets are moving much more.
Slowly. So.
Let's imagine now that we just want to get from earth to Jupiter.
So how would we do that?
We wouldn't send out a rocket pointed at Jupiter right now because Jupiter's
moving, Jupiter's moving slowly. The earth is moving a little bit more quickly.
And so what do we do the most efficient way to get from one orbit
to another is something called a homerun transfer orbit.
And this is beautiful and simple because all it needs are two
impulses, two changes of velocity.
And that will get you from earth to orbit eventually to Jupiter's orbit.
It's not the fastest way. It's the most efficient way.
It uses the least amount of fuel,
which is obviously going to be a big consideration when you're traveling around
the solar system,
that might not be the best way to do it in terms of human passengers and
protecting them for radiation, keeping them fed, watered and everything,
but in terms of pure rock.
Okay, efficiency.
Now I know from past experience that we've got many viewers out there
who are participants in the Kerbal space program,
which is a solar system simulator.
And I know that when I talk about the home and transfer orbits,
the hairs on the back of their neck will be going up and saying, okay, yes,
but there's more complicated orbits. And there's more things to think about.
And that's absolutely true. This, as many things are in,
um, our explanations of physics is simplified.
This is the simplest orbit to assuming that the two bodies are perfectly in the
same plane, it's seeming that they're starting on very circular orbits,
and it's neglecting the gravitational effects from other bodies.
That being said,
this is how you would get from earth to Jupiter using a home and transfer orbit.
All you have to do is at the right point,
you want to launch your spacecraft from earth.
Orbit will neglect getting off the earth.
We'll see more in the same orbit around the sun as the earth is.
And all you want to do is add velocity in a
tangential direction.
So we want to give it an instantaneous boost that way. What is that going to do?
We've known for hundreds of years,
since Kepler came up with his laws that beautifully described the motions of the
planets,
that the planets orbit the sun in elliptical orbits with the sun at one
focus. So if we're starting from a relatively circular orbit here,
and we add that impulse, we make this into bigger ellipse.
If we do it just right, we'll then follow an elliptical path.
And if we time it just right,
that elliptical orbit will have its furthest
distance from the sun it's app.
Helion right at the intersection with Jupiter's orbit.
So that gets us where we want to go. Now we just have to get the timing, right?
And so what we have to calculate is when to make that maneuver
in order that we catch up with Jupiter and we crossed that
orbit, it's not earth that's going.
And we crossed that orbit just as Jupiter gets there.
So that's only half the story though, because if that's all we do,
we'll fall back in on this orbit and we'll continue back into this nice
elliptical orbit that will cross Earth's orbit at one end and Jupiter's orbit at
the other.
And when space X launched the Tesla Roadster into orbit and said,
it was going to Mars, this is what it did.
It went into an orbit that took it across the orbit of Mars.
But then it's come back again and it's going to be in that Mars earth loop until
something else changes it. Oh, you can track it. I found a website.
So it is on its way back to earth orbit, not to earth, just like it.
Didn't get to Mars because Mars wasn't there. When it crossed Mars orbit,
it's going to come back to Earth's orbit,
but earth is going to be on the other side, right?
The sun will one day, will it get to one of them one day? Well,
one of them happened to be there when it will either get back to earth or Mars.
Assumably if it lasts long enough and you forward this info, you know,
infinitely, but what's more likely is that it will be broken up or disturbed or,
or something. The chances of it actually hitting either is very, very slim,
right? So we sent her spacecraft on a transfer orbit to Jupiter.
When we get there, if we don't do anything else to the spacecraft,
it's just going to follow this elliptical orbit.
We need to change its velocity again so that we match the orbital speed of
Jupiter. And so then you apply one more impulse.
So that's all you need is two impulses. Two changes in velocity.
One at Earth's orbit,
one at Jupiter's orbit tangential to the direction of the planet's travel.
It's called circularizes the orbit. You're going to change from that lip.
Tickle orbit into a nice circular orbit, matching Jupiter.
What is the impulse? When we get to Jupiter's orbit.
When we get to Jupiter,
we have to apply another tangential kick in velocity to speed up to
match Jupiter's orbital speed. Now,
if you wanted to get into Jupiter's orbit around Jupiter,
or if you wanted to land on Jupiter, that would require even more, um,
velocity change in terms of rocket trajectories,
we talked about a Delta V budget.
So Delta is the Greek symbol that we use for change.
And Delta V is just the total amount of velocity changes.
You need to make your maneuver happen.
Forget Jupiter for a minute for trying to land on Mars.
Some of that Delta V could be acquired through aerobraking.
If you want to land on a planet,
you need to slow down or you're just going to slam right into it.
So there's some atmosphere on Mars, not very much,
but some of that velocity you can lose by arrow breaking.
This would take 33 months to get from earth to Jupiter by this
orbital transfer. And that might not be what you want. So for example,
the new horizons spacecraft was sent on a mission to explore Pluto
and a transfer orbit to get from Earth's orbit to Pluto would take 46
years, which isn't so good.
If you're trying to plan your career and solve scientific problems,
that's a lot of waiting around in actual flag.
New horizons got Pluto in eight and a half years. How did that work? Well,
two things, first of all,
it wasn't trying to insert itself into orbit at Pluto's
distance from the sun or around Pluto.
It just wants screaming by really, really fast. And so there,
you don't have to worry about these beautiful ellipses.
You just apply as much rocket fuel as you can in the right direction at the
right time and off you go. And so when new horizons launched,
it was the fastest, um, object made by humans launched from the earth.
Okay? So what's screaming away from the earth at about 16 kilometers per second,
and that's enough to escape the solar system.
It was helped on the way by passing by Jupiter. So as,
as many of the outer system probes have it got a little kick,
it got a gravity boost by flying by Jupiter and by falling towards
Jupiter, it slowed down Jupiter, so many tiny amounts,
and some of that momentum was transferred to the spacecraft and sort of flung it
out, even further into the outer solar system.
This was used famously by the Voyager two spacecraft.
When the NASA scientists planning the mission realized there was a very
fortuitous alignment of planets,
which meant that they could visit not just Jupiter and Saturn,
but then change the trajectory to swing around and see Uranus and
Neptune.
Wow. It always seems funny to me that this doesn't slow them down.
Surely I would have thought there were ways in which going by something like
Jupiter would slow down hurdling out of the solar system.
It all depends on the direction in which you approach it.
And so these gravity slingshots can be used to slope spacecraft down
just as they can to speed them up.
And that's in fact how we get to the inner solar system.
You can imagine the solar system is this big, well, this gravity well,
and to get out, you have to apply energy and escape. And so you might think,
well,
it must be easy then to just roll down the Hill and drop down into the inner
solar system.
But that neglects the fact that we're traveling really fast
in a tangential direction around the sun. That's why we don't fall into the sun.
It's because we're traveling really, really,
really fast in a sideways direction.
That's why when we try to send things into orbit around the earth,
we don't just send things straight up and then they don't come down again.
We send things up, get them through the atmosphere.
Then we send them sideways really, really fast.
And what happens then is that they're constantly falling towards the earth,
but they're falling so fast that they keep missing it continuously and falling
round around the other side,
just as we're continuously missing the sun as we fall around the solar system.
And so what do we need to do to get into the inner solar system?
We need to slow down some of that sideways motion. So we did the same thing,
apply a tangential Delta V to our spacecraft velocity.
But this time we're not trying to add velocity to it.
We're trying to take away velocity.
And when we take away some of that sideways earth motion,
we start to fall towards the inner solar system.
And this is how we've got spacecraft to Venus, to mercury.
And most recently how we've sent the parkers.
Probe once the sun liftoff, Oh,
the mighty Delta for heavy rocket with NASA's Parker, solar probe,
a daring mission to shed light on the mysteries of our closest star. The sun.
Is a spacecraft that is designed to get as close as we've ever been
to the sun.
It will actually pass within 10 times the radius of the sun.
It'll fly through the solar Corona,
the outer atmosphere of the sun to try to learn about it.
It's an incredible mission.
It's not a straightforward maneuver to just cancel out all of this earth,
orbital motion. Again,
they are using this time Venus for a fly by,
and this time we're going to do exactly what you suggested is come at it from
the other direction,
which will speed Venus up a tiny bit and slow the Parker,
solar probe down enough to gradually change its orbit into a
nice tight elliptical orbit.
That's going to send it eventually screaming round the sun at
0.06%.
The speed of light when it reaches its maximum orbital velocity in
2024.
And it's going to take seven flybys of Venus to make that happen.
Sounded like current Mars probes get there pretty much.
This is the way that we are restricted to at the moment until we build much
bigger, um,
propulsion systems or much more efficient propulsion systems.
We are simply stuck with the fact that doing anything else would
require so much fuel both on the beginning end,
but also at the other end that it's just not practical to do anything but the
most efficient maneuvers. Now there are obviously some subtleties,
there are some extra things that you can do here.
You can do powered Slingshot maneuvers, where you fire your engine,
right at the deepest part of the potential. Well,
that's the most efficient place to add the extra impulse,
but by and large, we are restricted to these launch windows,
for which everything lines up just right,
so that we can send things in the most efficient manner.
Is it going to be this way when we start sending to other stars.
As well? Is that how it's going to work? Is it going to be, you know,
where's this star going to be when we launched this thing and that,
or is it there's going to be other ways of doing this by that time.
There may be some really interesting technologies with solar sales,
just catching the solar wind and just very slowly,
but consistently accelerating to a very high velocity and then reversing that
somehow on the other end.
Oh,
where's Andromeda going to be in 10,000 years and something and sending things.
I mean, this is something astronomers have to worry about. Um,
just in terms of finding our way around the sky, everything is moving.
The stars are apparently moving, um,
on time skills that we can measure on timescales that cause problems for us as
astronomers. And so if you're trying to get from one place to another,
depending on what those timescales are, yeah.
You have to take into account that everything is moving relative to everything
else, but that's going to be a long way away.
You were two videos on my objectivity channel. I'd love it.
If you go and have a look at them, they're new ones.
One is about the American Apollo moon rocks.
And this other one is about some grains of sand brought back from the moon by
the Soviets. I'll put links on the screen and in the description,
I think you might enjoy them. 26 grains of sand.
You just held a piece of the moon. How cool is that? Indeed, because these 26.
Grains of sand are Russian Moondust.
So this is Apollo 15 sample 54, one five. It's the Genesis rock.